yeah so my name is Alex Levitt I'm
currently a researcher facebook today
though I will not be talking about
Facebook instead I'll be talking about
another platform which you might be
familiar with reddit com which was the
case study for my dissertation research
in grad school so today I'm going to be
talking about the people's news
high-tempo pure information aggregation
in response to developing events before
I start I'd also just like to thank Mike
Bernstein for the invitation as well as
Stanford for hosting I'm really excited
to be here so the people's news what
exactly does that mean it's a play on
words for the sake of of talk and it's
specifically referencing a few points of
interest which you might be familiar
with so the first is Wikipedia which is
colloquially known as the people's
encyclopedia where people come together
strangers from all over the world and
participate in networks information
production so it's a system that allows
collaboration from distributed
individuals all around the world that
creates something new and helpful and
then there's the people's Mike which you
might be familiar with with the recent
protests the people's mike is
essentially a protest technique that
helps amplify the voice of one person
across the entire crowd producing what
might be called a sense of network
visibility and these two concepts
networked information production and
network visibility are really key to the
third concept which from introducing now
which is the people's news and when I
say news you might think of things like
the New York Times or Fox News or even
Twitter nowadays what you might not
think of is something like a common
thread on a website that not many people
use such as this where you have
extremely up to date relevant and
informative information presented in a
way that millions of people are around
the world can access it immediately so
today we'll be talking about red calm
it's a social news site where people can
contribute information
and then vote on that information to
either get it really high on its
homepage or hide it if it gets low
amounts of votes and i'll be talking
about the implications that network
collaboration has on that platform for
information dissemination around
breaking news situations so again quick
about me i got my PhD this past year
2016 at the Annenberg School for
Communication in Los Angeles of the
University of Southern California the
case study again is reddit com and to
note I have been on reddit for a number
of years now both as a ordinary user and
a participant observer if anyone is a
fellow redditor let's say I am on Team
periwinkle my focus generate for
research is on collaboration on the
Internet specifically around
interactions on social media and online
game and previously I've also worked at
Sony Playstation just the interactive
microsoft research and MIT doing this
kind of research trying to help
designers and engineers understand
people's everyday lives as they interact
with social media systems and i'm
currently at facebook research one note
this talk is going to be pretty high
level so i'm not going to go into the
nitty-gritty of the details of the
research because i figured that you can
spend your own time reading that
research if you want to if you're
interested the worker in my dissertation
is available at the first link and i
also have some other papers that you
might be interested in as well the first
one is a paper that was published at chi
in 2014 and that one is looking at a
particular subreddit and how they
coordinated to produce breaking news
around a hurricane it's a bit more
quantitative if you're that inclined and
then my most recent paper which will be
presented actually this month at the
cscw conference is more about this
aspect of producing visibility in
breaking news situation so if you're so
inclined feel free to check those links
out and I can share them at the end of
the talk as well so today I'm going to
talk about four things the first is this
idea of peer information aggregation and
the role of the citizen journalists
whatever that means
the second is understanding what pure
information aggregation is specifically
these choices and group collaboration
particularly within the context of
reddits design thinking through comment
threads and this live blogging format
the third is given the research that
I've done what do we now know about news
practices on reddit and then fourth if
we can just discuss the design
implications for the future and for this
fourth point actually given that the
seminar has kind of experimented with
different formats what we're actually
going to do is a quick activity at the
end so everyone will get out of their
seats run around the room real quick and
you can start to empathize with the
people who are doing this kind of
breaking news aggregation work okay so
let's start in 2012 in Aurora Colorado
you might be familiar where a shooter
entered a theater in a late night
showing of the then recent Batman movie
he ended up shooting into a number of
theaters killing a number of people and
what was interesting is that because
this happened at a very particular point
in the evening or late at night kind of
going into the morning many of the
general news agencies were not on top of
the story however there were some people
who are in top of the story and it ended
up being aggregated on reddit now reddit
is just this website where you can go
and comment about funny cat videos and
share information about the world and no
one really expects reddit to be a place
where you can get quality information
that we would consider new but at the
time around this event it was the first
place that many people were doing
because a number of volunteer users were
finding different sources from all over
the Internet weather or Twitter or
mainstream media whether it's police
scanners or other sources of information
and they helped each other by collecting
the information vetting it and then
aggregating it all into one place
creating this narrative over the course
of two or three weeks just constantly
updating information
people and what's interesting is that a
number of journalists actually
considered that they had been scooped by
reddit that this kind of wiki style
collaboration was now a new form of
journalism in and of itself and we can
understand too that news on reddit well
it's not a particularly common practice
you don't think of Reddit as the place
where you would immediately go to get
news it is the common practice for many
people so here you can see traffic
statistics around a particular
earthquake and how they immediately jump
when people are going to access
information when they need it most in a
particular situation and as I said
before this was a unique moment for a
lot of journalists Matt Ingram who is a
technology journalist said that this is
a moment where reddit has essentially
become what wikinews wanted to be
wikinews being a Wikipedia style
experiment where people could edit news
articles in the same way that Wikipedia
could back in 2007 which never really
took off in the way that news reporting
and news aggregation on reddit have so
what I want to do is essentially jump
into what exactly peer information
aggregation is and what it does for a
community and a platform like Reddit and
then understand how design implications
kind of play out when we understand the
behaviors of this kind of ad hoc
high-tempo information practice so the
kind of research that I was doing was
very qualitative it's a bit weird to say
that because i am now much more a person
who runs regressions and we'll set
machine learning models but this was
very much grounded in a number of years
of ethnographic fieldwork but also
paired with a more computational social
science bent so what that means is it's
been a number of years in these
community boards just watching what
people did I also sat down face-to-face
with people for over 50 interviews
trying to understand their retrospective
behaviors and their perspectives on why
they were doing this and how they were
doing those what's unique too is that I
was able to situate the
ethnographic work in a very large data
set which comprises over 2 billion posts
and comments from the entirety of reddit
history and what that meant was I could
use computational means to dig into case
studies of which I used over 350
specific comments post live threads
moderators and administrators trying to
understand these very unique moments in
which people were aggregating
information and what the difficulties
decisions and values are that they had
at those points in time and what this
looks like is of course like literally
sitting down and talking to people but
also digging through databases using
machine learning algorithms to
understand unique temporal trends and
trying to surface anomalies that could
then point me at better more distinct
case studies throughout the analysis the
people I talked to were very unique as
well so in the 53 interviews about half
of them were outside of the United
States they were english-speaking but
what that meant was I could get
perspectives from people all over the
world a majority of them did happen to
be white or Caucasian especially in the
US and a very small amount of them where
women this tends to be the kind of
generic community that read it attracts
however what this means is we have a
very distinct perspective on types of
participation that can happen in
communities so I would focus less
perhaps on the particular demographics
and more on the actual expressed values
and ways in which they decide to do this
kind of work now what exactly are we
talking about when we think about
information aggregation on reddit well a
normal aggregation kind of looks like
this some big mass of information and
you're really looking at it after the
fact have to kind of tease it apart from
many different directions so what this
means is that people will find
information from many different sources
around the web and then aggregate news
updates in one central location they
will find it shared media from around
the web whether it's photos uploaded by
people on the ground or videos produced
by mainstream media organizations
it's even information from other users
where people will comment or send
private messages or sit in an IRC
channel for hours constantly paying the
people who are updating these threads
with new information and corrections
frequently too we see that people are
sharing emergency information because
people comment how can I help in this
situation I'm so many miles away but
perhaps I can put people in contact with
the information that they need and
what's key too is that the issue of
visibility completely interacts with how
people think about this work so again
reddit works on this up though and
download system where if you get more
uploads you get more visibility because
of the post that you're interacting with
it sits on top of the homepage and so
people are constantly in a battle to
upload and download information that
they think is correct or that they want
to hide so that they can bring
visibility to these very momentary
relevant pieces of information as people
react to these developing of Em's and
Bretta has changed their approach to
these situations as well so here is the
kind of generic way that people did this
a number of years ago like four or five
years ago where they would just kind of
appropriate a common thread and
continually update that until they hit a
character limit and then have to do it
in another post until reddit developed
what's known as a live reddit feature
which is essentially a live blog where
people can automatically throw
information and and it aggregates that
very nicely and dozens of people can
coordinate at the same time and you can
see essentially that this is just like
one half an hour of a two-week
conversation where tons of pieces of
information are just aggregated again
and again and again from many different
users and so this idea of aggregation
the process of collecting and organizing
information becomes very key to what is
going on and read it which is
essentially not really what journalists
are doing journalists are going out into
the world and evaluating information and
collecting it and producing it into news
which is this very
professional products of journalistic
organizations but what people are doing
here is more around information they're
going out into the world they're
evaluating what different people say
about certain things and that they're
collecting it for people to evaluate
themselves it's not saying that a
journalistic organization has evaluated
all this entirely is that people are
given the responsibility to figure out
what is correct given a particular
narrative that a user generates and so
peer information aggregation is a very
complex situation it starts with
information from all different sources
on the line whether it's mainstream
media news journalistic information
where people aren't really quite sure if
it's correct expert info like press
releases or police scanners and even
user-generated content all just gets put
into this massive collection of
information these aggregated posts and
live threads from volunteer people who
are users of the system and what's key
is the aggregation relies on only a
little experience and mostly on values
and a lot of timing so the fact that you
might get there first means that you are
immediately responsible for doing this
work over the course of hours or even
days in participants think about what
kind of information they want to include
what kind of sources they draw from and
how they will go about verifying the
information at every single step of the
way design of course implicates this
work a lot so the fact that you need to
post in a comment thread and be aware of
the limitations that the system imposes
on that work and perhaps you might be
doing this by yourself you might be
doing it with one or two other people or
you might be doing it with dozens of
people there are many different ways
that collaboration kind of plays out in
these emergent fashions what's key to is
the process of feedback so this constant
cycle of the network providing input on
to these aggregated contributions saying
hey thank you for doing this hey here's
some new information hey actually this
part is incorrect you should try and fix
it and this process of feedback going
through the governance of the crowd as
well as the governance of moderators and
administrators of the platform are key
to how people do this work as well
and pure aggregation constantly evolves
over time and because of this such an
emergent practice it really revolves
around the content iteration from past
case studies there's no rules really
that exists here and always keep in mind
too that this work is continually
constructed by the platform because in a
somewhat technologically deterministic
way the way that people see this
information is because of the way the
system works because people manipulate
the algorithms to produce disability to
specific instances of information in
these very specific moments of crisis so
I want to dip really quickly into some
of the findings so that you can get a
better understanding of not only who
these people are but what exactly
they're doing and the complicated
process of doing this work so who
exactly are they well in general
participants would perceive reddit as a
viable alternative for news but not
necessarily the place where music is if
they see that there are differences in
source variety speed and crowd
participation compared to other
platforms specifically mainstream media
sites but they would say find different
comparisons between the speed that
Twitter operates and sharing information
and the way that reddit does they
typically are volunteers who have little
to no experience with professional news
reporting which you might consider to be
complicated and controversial but a lot
of what they think about is how they
have seen this exists in prior
situations on reddit and how that would
then influence how they do their own
work moving forward there are a number
of past events that have shaped it
significantly such as the Boston
Marathon bombing which is kind of
colloquially known as a very bad example
of how collaboration can work because
they couldn't go identified the wrong
suspect and then made that very popular
but there are many successful examples
of this as well now as what in terms of
why someone would actually do this in
the first place there tend to be
threefold motivations so the first is
that someone feels like they have
individual local or topical expertise
the second is that they perceive needs
of imagined or actual audiences so that
maybe they feel like the reddit
community needs to know this or they
actually have people contacting them
because they said they were local to the
event and finally what really motivates
people to is that there's the expectancy
of network involvement it's kind of like
this Wikipedia ethos where the fact that
read it connects so many people around
the world that they can rely on that
network to help produce this information
what's more interesting too is the way
that people think about values so first
is that there is a recognition of events
based on mainstream media reporting and
user-generated content information
surgeries and what I mean by that is the
fact that someone pays attention to any
particular event is because they see
someone start talking about it and
frequently that means a lot of people
are talking about it for example the
paris marathon bombings you might go on
twitter and see tons of tweets popping
up being like hey was there an explosion
here what exactly is going on in france
bigger stories tend to also lead to more
response and more incentive to
participate so there are a number of
taste studies that I looked at where
they were like local situations maybe a
robbery or a school shooting but also
these massive global events like again
Paris where people gained so much
attention and the international
community is so focused on the media
being produced around it that it really
encourages people to participate in
those situations and what's interesting
to again kind of drawing from this
Wikipedia ethos is striving for facts
and objective information meaning that
people strive to find the most precise
information in the moment even though it
is very difficult in a high-tempo ad-hoc
situation to determine that given that
there is a lot of information
misinformation and bias kind of
architecting any particular system but
these news values really do impact how
gatekeeping works in this situation
where someone is determining what to
include in a post or what not to include
it all comes back to the particular
values that they hold now what exactly
are the practices of peer aggregation so
part of what you need to understand is
just how weather is architected it's a
a network of communities where you can
post into a community and there are
particular social norms and behaviors
within each community but users can
bleed across communities and participate
in different ones as well because
they're all connected on the same
technical Network and so what that means
that there are entry points that vary
across subreddits these sub communities
and it means that participants will
engage with different algorithms in each
community to find news in different ways
and that also means that because there
are multiple ways to participate on each
one people will participate on each one
and there are multiple postings that
complicate these entry points into
getting involved in news production so
for example during the Paris attacks in
2015 you can see the various activity
and a number of different subreddits so
it starts in places like the news
subreddit the France suffered at the
World News subreddit the Europe
subreddit but it bleeds into things that
you wouldn't even expect to find news in
such as the pics subreddit the advice
animals it's a meme subreddit the shower
thoughts subreddit all these people
start talking about news as it bleeds
across these connected communities and
what complicates those two is you're
never quite sure where to look first to
find the information that you need and
so people need to coordinate as they
start updating about these events what's
also confusing to is most people tend to
only look at the homepage and that isn't
the only algorithm that sorts news on
reddit or information on reddit you can
go to the new algorithm Q which surfaces
every single new item that's submitted
to a community and you can see in
breaking news situations how that might
get complicated because everyone's
trying to share everything immediately
so here in just the first few a few
minutes of the aftermath of the Paris
attacks everything highlighted here is
related to Paris and you wouldn't
necessarily know if you are scrolling
through all of these where exactly you
would want to start commenting to help
people start aggregating there are also
different ways that people start
emerging in their practices around
formatting this information as well and
again this kind of goes back to the
values what do I include what do I not
include but also because you have an
imagined audience you need to understand
how people might consume the information
and how you want to present it to them
so generally participants will format
with like bullet points and summaries
there will be long contributions
depending on the size of the event so
you might have anything from a few
paragraphs all the way to dozens and
dozens of full ten thousand character
posts sometimes it's common to use
timestamps and the addition of emergency
information people do it but it gets
complicated because at every single
moment when you're aggregating this
information you have to make a
split-second decision do I include this
do i include that if I include this it's
going to spend time away from doing
something else people generally relied
on the post and common structure of
course but as live threads became more
popular it was easier to add more people
to them but also harder to organize
everyone and gain attention to these
threads as well just a quick summary of
some data to you can see the varying
distributions of the kind of practices
that people would use so for example in
many cases people did not use
Corrections there's kind of a 50-50
split on whether someone would use a
summary format versus a bullet point
format frequently people don't use
emergency info but in the cases where
they do it's very poignant you can see
here for example that a lot of people
will refer to news organizations at
least one so there is a reliance on
mainstream media however in many cases
there aren't people who are actually
local to the event who are participating
in these aggregation threads and going
back to this idea of values and how it
integrates with practice when people
choose the information to include there
is a perceived relevance and that's
really key to what gets chosen on what
doesn't as I said before there is a
strong dependence on professional news
sources as well so if you had no
experience sharing information about
breaking news and you had to pick one
place to go where would you
it's probably going to be the thing that
your most used to going to which is
probably like CNN or the BBC it's
probably not going to be someone who you
don't trust who's just sharing things on
Twitter there's also a preference for
multiple sources to provide perspective
but usually it kind of again falls back
to this idea that there are sources that
are trustworthy and those tend to be
generally more preferred what's
confusing too is you also have to keep
in mind that misinformation might kind
of leak in here and there and so vetting
this information generally involves
triangulation of multiple sources if
something has been said three times
across three places that you trust it's
probably going to be something that you
include if you hear it once probably
less likely so and some participants do
feel comfortable sharing unconfirmed
information but others will edit posts
much later so it becomes very
complicated insofar as when an audience
member interacts with this aggregated
information whether something that's
wrong is corrected at the time when they
read it or not and as I said at the very
beginning of the talk overall one of the
people who do this work put the
responsibility not on themselves but on
the readers of the information they know
that they themselves are volunteers and
they know that there is this kind of
semblance of a feeling that read it
isn't really a place where you should
get your news but they're doing this
work because it helps get information
out there helpful link people the
sources and therefore people should kind
of come at it from the perspective of
I'm not really sure if this is true and
I should really be the one to evaluate
the information as I go through it step
by step and so here for example you can
see that a simple edit would be crossed
out and a correction placed underneath
and that would be as about as much as
you would get for corrective information
sometimes two people would use different
different affordances of the platform to
make corrections more visible so for
example here there is
there is a flare oh there it is it's
kind of hard to see it says pyrotechnics
may have caused fighter so you can
actually edit titles when you submit
information to rent it just because
people would game that system a lot but
moderators have implemented small tweaks
so that you can use these affordances of
the platform to provide immediate
visibility to certain information over
others now finally what about
collaboration so as I said before there
is a distinct difference between people
who are kind of appropriating comment
and post threads and just using the
system for their own means to get out
information and people who are shifting
more towards this developed design
system the reddit live blog format now
what becomes complicated is it's pretty
easy to do this individually up to the
extent that you're constantly like
shifting through 14 tabs in your browser
and watching three live streams and
trying to aggregate all that information
but the thing is you start require
admitting more people into your into
your workflow it gets more complicated
part of that complication is you need to
add people that you trust and so adding
additional people requires vetting
usually this would be based on
reputation and timing so the fact that
someone was there and said they would
help you that might be good enough but
maybe someone who in you you're not
sure if you should trust them so you'll
spend a good minute going through their
entire reddit history seeing what they
post maybe if they're posting to like a
Nazi subreddit you might not want them
to be reporting on something
collaboration also employs explicit
coordination in small teams whereas the
larger group collaboration relies on
implicit coordination and what that
means is X plus a coordination is
essentially direct communication it's
usually accomplished by lead users so
that means that we are directly
communicating with each other an even
closer coordination is unspoken
expectations and shared mental models so
that's more like I see what someone is
doing and I have some thing in my head
of what they're doing so I'm going to do
something else that complements that and
what happens is small teams where it's
like one or two or three people there's
a lot of X
the coordination that occurs it's slower
because you don't have as many people
but there's much more coordinated action
going on whereas larger groups
especially in these alive threads they
have to rely on inputs of coordination
because there isn't a communication
infrastructure that underlies the entire
system where people can communicate in a
back channel and so they have to see
given the other 29 people who are
helping submit information here what can
I do to help complement them without
just repeating information and causing
information overflow and finally to
moderators who are helping a moderate
the system tend to use more explicit
coordination because they're already
coordinated they work every day together
in back channels that they've set up to
help monitor their sub communities and
so they kind of appropriate those back
channels to help coordinate other users
and so that does help a little bit as
well here's this a quick example of what
that coordination between individuals
looks like so it's just one person is
responding hey can you fill in for me
and then someone steps in people go back
and forth switching off this case study
here with mr. gnw and de facto idiot one
persons in the United States and one
person's in Malaysia switching back and
forth during different time zones
there's also the coordination of
different users so for example here
blatant conservatives calls forth people
who he knows have worked on breaking
news aggregation in the past and they
are able to coordinate bringing together
a new live thread to then report much
more distinctly about a particular topic
instead of getting lost in in tons of
comments that just kind of gets filtered
down in a thread and again shifting the
life threads is complicated because
people can work together very very
conveniently in one thread and it ever
gets all the information very neatly and
it shows it in this kind of reverse
chronological order which is very
convenient but you can't just create a
thread and immediately have people gain
visibility to it so usually people will
create common threads and then link
alive thread and then suddenly you have
to
convince everyone to shift over and
start uploading the other thread and
that coordination of visibility becomes
very difficult as well so finally what
are the conflicts that arise between
human and design Oh as I said multiple
times disability becomes a huge issue
here and these concerns about visibility
really do shape how people do the work
that they do in these breaking news
situations part of the complication is
that there's a rich richer trend where
things that are already visible are the
things that people vote on which then
just become more popular and so if
something new happens that needs to gain
visibility you have to again shift ever
and over to start voting on that and
convince them not to help with the other
one there's also competition with other
posts so earlier I showed all of the new
things that appear around there breaking
news event and you have to convince
everyone to focus on one instead of
focusing on a few and so therefore
timing becomes especially critical to
the success of ranking in this kind of
feed based system and therefore there
are also unintended consequences so that
could mean anything from hitting a
character cap to getting something
deleted by a moderator there are just so
many unknowns that happen here and when
you're constantly making split-second
decisions trying to get information out
to the world and something goes wrong
that's five minutes that you have to
waste trying to figure out why it went
wrong and then trying to get back in in
into the flow sometimes manual
visibility has become a practice so for
example the administrators during
Hurricane sandy back in 2014 just put an
advertisement up on the front page and
that redirected people into a subreddit
to specifically talk about the heart
game but frequently people just don't
understand how the complications work
like how the platform encounters these
problems so for example shanky here just
doesn't understand if you can edit the
title of a post or not and again in
these very ad hoc moments high tempo
moments
having to deal with these issues really
slows down the process of aggregating
the work in coordinating with other
people and also to mention too sometimes
the servers just go down so during the
2015 Paris attacks a number of
aggregators in Europe just lost contact
with rabbit as a site because the
servers got so overloaded with people
trying to gain information and finally
there's also design user roles so
moderators and administrators have
various privileges that conflict with
these expectations about how the system
should work so people will go in and
delete things without any explanation
and that will consistently confuse
people from a moderate ish perspective
and I talked to a number of them they
see this as a need for goals whether
it's providing balance or instituting
rules but for people who are aggregating
information and feeling like they're
contributing to something in the moment
they feel extremely kind of negatively
impacted by these decisions and again as
I said before manual production of
visibility is not accessible to everyone
it would probably be a handful of
administrators at reddit HQ or maybe a
couple of moderators who could provide
immediate visibility's of something so
there's constantly a conflict between
the crowd meeting can provide a
visibility through uploading or
contributing new information and the
immediate decisions that a moderator
could make in any one moment and you can
see here for example during a Los
Angeles earthquake these are all of the
posts that a moderator deleted that he
felt was not necessarily valid compared
to the one that he chose that was and
that one ended up being one of the first
ones and people feel like they need to
contribute all this stuff but part of
that I ideal situation is providing
immediate visibility the one thing while
also having to provide balance because
this would be very overwhelming for
someone trying to find a lot of
information about the event what's
interesting too is some users have tried
to get around these situations so they
use infrastructure like automated bus
but sometimes they don't always work and
users don't understand why and also as I
said before moderators will delete the
out of the blue and users have to
respond immediately to this as they get
inundated with messages from their
audiences saying hey why did you delete
that thing and they have to respond I
don't know what happened maybe a
moderator deleted it and they have to
respond immediately as fast as they can
so peer information aggregation is a
thing that exists it doesn't necessarily
have to be high tempo and it doesn't
necessarily have to be in the moment but
when you combine it with developing
events it means that you have this very
complicated process of information
circulation tangled with traditional
information flows from things like
mainstream media professional
journalists and it's explicitly shaped
by technological design especially
around issues of visibility and it's
extremely ad-hoc but really realize that
provides human decision-making in the
moment and that's complicated and
there's no really good solution but as
we can look at these examples and
understand where those complications
start appearing we can start to
understand people's behaviors and the
ways in which they use their values and
motivations and decisions to influence
of kind of work and then we can start
designing better systems that actually
speak to those needs so this kind of
aggregation is not a replacement at all
for mainstream journalism but it does
exist as this kind of quasi-independent
/ dependent system that is alongside and
augments news in general we can also
take advantage of the affordances of
networked audiences but it's key that
when you're doing this work people will
probably put the responsibility on the
audiences rather than the people doing
the work and that gets very complicated
because you can't really do moderation
when something is super emergent like
this and it's always clear to keep in
mind that design shapes practices but
also it shapes expectations of those
practices and introduces conflicts as
well and so unless we understand not
only what people are doing but what kind
of mentality they brought to what they
were doing that's when we can start to
design these systems but
to help establish kind of common ground
across different use cases so that we
can have something that's universally
adoptable and easy to pick up okay so
this is all I have now I want to do an
emphasizing activity I have no idea if
this is going to work I have no idea if
this is going to be fun but I think it
will help you realize how difficult this
kind of work is so what we're going to
do is around the room I have placed
little sheets of paper they have a
letter and a number on it there's a b c
and d and ABCD refer two stages of
information access so you'll start with
a will move to be will move to see you
almost d the numbers don't matter so
much as they just represent distinct
sources of information that you could
use so the goal of this activity is you
want on your team to create the most
precise accurate and well-rounded set of
updates about the break news event and
you're going to write it out on paper
which I have here with the letter and
the number so you can track your sources
you don't need to include all the
information that's out there but you do
need to make decisions about what to
include within the allotted time so at
the end of this activity you'll have a
piece of paper with a bunch of
information and your sources and we'll
split into two types of teams so you
should find people next to you you
should have teams of four you can either
be the editorial post where one person
is the editor and osarian tease of five
and four contributors so the editor will
be the person writing and the for
contributors will go run around and find
information or you can be on the
collaborative feed where it's five
contributors everyone will be writing
information down but you need to do it
in order so the editor can do anything
that they want essentially and the
collaborative feed just needs to write
write
eight per person what's key though is
that on the editor side you can talk
anytime but only the editor can compile
information on the collaborative need
side you can talk anytime you're not
writing but as soon as you get to that
piece of paper you can't talk around the
piece of paper so you have to only look
at what everyone else was putting on the
piece of paper so as you can see this
kind of like the common thread is more
alive thread now here's what the game
comes in you get 20 points for each
update written out in full you get 10
points if you paraphrases on each of the
piece of the paper there are two metrics
there's speed and risk you get bonus
points if it says speed you get minus
points on risk if the information turns
out to be wrong some of the pieces of
paper have Corrections on them so you
can cross out what the correction of so
here's the activity get into your group
of four or five each of the phases will
have three minutes so we'll do three
minutes per phase a three minutes for be
three minutes for see three minutes for
d don't look at the pieces of paper they
have sticky notes over the information
and we will reveal the information
underneath during each phase I have
markers and paper up here
you're given forfeit your watch we have
to check first with oh yeah I suppose I
got there yes so we're going to start
with a don't reveal B C or D we will
reveal be after three minutes will we
real see three minutes after that and
then we're we will reveal d after that
so just things let's say a it's up to
you to go find a how do we know you're
thinking shoes focus yeah this is the
paper can move of fun as long as the
collaborative speed does not talk around
your paper yeah can I get a raise the
hands just who is on a team right now
okay cool that's probably enough and
everyone else can watch out chaotic fufu
ok so we're going to start with a now
you get three minutes yes there should
be a couple of days your team string
right on one piece of paper yes
ya go you should be going the whole
thing yeah so if it has an 8 take out
all the sticky note you gonna other end
now yes other you can decide to include
all A's and you want although feel free
to grab another piece of paper if you
want to coordinate bringing back to your
team information from around the room
all right it seems like everyone's
already on a we're going to trip to be
you have three minutes don't cover all
the B's go
[Music]
remember to include the letter and
number of the finger writing down so
that we can track your sources to
realize yes with a little bit of stuff
so I'm going to knock it down in two
minutes per phase beat it up
okay we want to see now that is the sea
uncover see have you ever won
[Music]
okay can I see if two minutes if two
minutes to finish the entire thing and
then we'll tell their point
no one thought see for it here there's
another see if you want to check it out
it might be important there's also d 5
of 9 55 so I think you have miss
underestimated the value of using cell
phones are you sergeant second you don't
know that the many people w another to
you I do they do yeah good yes it was a
good reflection of reality they're fine
so what do these uh it depends it can be
anywhere from IRC to skype to black to
just private messages to Twitter
moderators use different channel
part of the hard part of the project is
such a message you have to find trends
and like every possible scenario yeah
all right that's it separating things no
more talking okay how did you do
visually ones you ok so how you'll tally
up do this on your own team so for every
single update you wrote give yourself 20
points if you paraphrase though only get
result 10 point if there were any
sources that had a seed number on it and
you can go around and check with you are
there were babysitting and the Ember
points as well but there were some bits
of misinformation so if you didn't cross
out the ones that I read off subtract
the risk number on that source so the
ones you subtract our 40 points for a 2
yep
no in a week EMI and 4b for a new was
Twitter on g-force you before with local
news update correction has been made the
correction will follow you can- pen for
c1 that's the BBC reports are coming in
[Music]
original however if you did find d1 it
had a correction so if you cross that
the one that was wrong earlier you
cannot subtract the points for here
[Music]
don't feel bad
we won't have fun if you if you if you
have been like blessed day for a true if
you keep the toy store when it dropped
out no I'm gonna be out of action
[Music]
we can throw away yeah some fun did you
guys get italian air air on identical
courses together or my permission for
the first 20 points for agencies to each
of us wrote an opulent are also we add a
20 point for each of dietary business or
for the entire just three sheep it with
the river an output converter very
reasonable doesn't mean a little
variously then the numbers today one in
people in their computer cool what do a
quick to you and debrief we can do that
for another like 15 minutes or something
with that hard sure is confusing which
it was meant to be but did people feel
like they had to evaluate different
sources or did you just write everything
down right one
doing a battering ram do you really feel
like it won't move the one can you
please get out later it's done did
everyone catch my version yeah they
might not catch aggression Dylan shoes
collaboratively as a lot of people
talking I did not did you work okay not
talking to each other when you were
writing part of the difficulties that I
have found when talking to people is
especially when you get to like 20 25 30
people in a single thread there's just
so much chaos and what happens is people
will say that they felt like they
contributed a lot but that there was so
much repetition that it wasn't valuable
for people who are actually looking at
it so part of the difficulty here is
that this design is so much easier for
people to use but it's pretty bad on the
consumer end whereas this one is much
more harder to coordinate but it's much
more interactive for the people who are
doing the work and also much more easier
to read for people at the end but what
is also hard is you have a limit for
this one so if you have to create like
14 threads just because you keep hitting
a comment a character cap because you
can only put in 10,000 characters for
every post because reddit never expected
people to use them this way that's why
they developed this so you can keep this
going for weeks whereas this one is
definitely not sustainable if you have
to be like all right like red number 9
everyone go upload thread number 9 up
we're switching the 10 everyone go up a
thread number 10 yes I will shoot for
classified it is there can you do to
this type of reporting because I had
that set at things get left catastrophic
in people's motivation
without you a pic it wouldn't be as
useful yeah go to very one and I'm
coming I did see in talking with people
where there would be some people who
started reporting on an event and it
ended up not being particularly
important or or crisis II and so it kind
of fizzled out for them they usually
said that they felt pretty good about
being there in the moment and like
contributing to something at the start
but once they realize that it wasn't
taking off as a breaking news event it
just wasn't worth spending the time to
them and so yeah this is definitely a
practice that tends to be more in
response to developing events and what I
found generally is that people tend to
rely on it much more in that situation
because mainstream media especially
doesn't have like a definitive source of
information it's all about trying to
triangulate all the different sources
that are reporting on it because one
news agency might have a really good new
piece of information whereas the next
best piece of information comes from
like someone on the ground with their
cell phone and so aggregating all that
information in one space gives people
are a much grander and narrative of
what's going on that you wouldn't
necessarily get from news agencies
because they're competing they're still
businesses so you'll never get like the
full narrative or news agencies linking
to other news agencies and that's why
people find it valuable I'm you know
between again I'm puzzled about using
the reddit platform which is mr. kind of
more slower aggregation and curation
information because this purpose means
because of it so what would you say
about why you spread it yeah I think
even the people who built read it didn't
expect people to have it used in this
way and I think just over time there
were a number of communities related to
reporting on Daily News that started
sharing news about breaking events and
people felt that there was a need to
kind of keep updated about certain
things most of the early kind of
aggregation threads tended to be around
natural disasters so especially things
like earthquakes floods but then you see
that spill over into like mass shootings
airplane disappearances stuff like that
and I think reddit has realized that the
system itself isn't conducive to doing
this work either so especially the
dynamics of how the algorithm surface
information and the speed at which it
does it has changed over time so maybe
two or three years ago as soon as the
breaking news event happened it would be
on the top of the front page nowadays it
takes like 30 minutes to two hours for
that to happen just because so many
other things are being aggregated into
the algorithm and the way that the
algorithm sort stuff just doesn't
surface it in time and so actually they
announced last week that they are
officially working on changing the
algorithm so that it could produce
different dynamics for different
communities and it's DVD on whether
that's good or bad but we'll see how it
works
I was like imagine your leader I want to
be sort of developing thread and you
want to think about where you have the
most impact in terms of contributing a
way that isn't giving actual information
about it and like loading it if I was
thinking about sorting comments by like
you comments or controversial comments
without those matter more a lot of water
the other of those two swords yeah so I
think both and it depends on the time
during the event so early on the things
that are tops probably matter most
because the comment that tends to be the
most popular is the one that has the
aggregated information in it but what
get complicated is as new developments
occur people will comment underneath the
main comment saying like hey this thing
just happened mobile blah and getting
visibility on those new updates is
really complicated because you have to
get everyone to band together and start
uploading that what can happen is people
will private message the original editor
and say like hey I saw that you didn't
include this link but like here's a new
update and maybe though have enough time
to start reading their messages and then
include it later but frequently what
happens is you get a message for every
single comment that someone makes so you
already have like 500 comments and then
you have another 500 people messaging
you saying hey includes a sling so part
of its like do you stay on top of the
new sources do you pay attention to the
network with giving you information are
you even paying attention to the
corrections you need to make how many
sources can you look at the same time I
had people say they will get to only I
had people say they was at 14 or 15 at
the same time just trying to get as much
as they could and I think I'm being the
day it's just very emergent and ad-hoc
depending on the person and so going
back to the to the common question like
it really just depends on the dynamic at
the moment and you kind of hope that the
community is able to react appropriately
to surface the right information
other than that it has been found me
like more example helpful here's why
it's not so chaotic for 50 people would
be a lot babe you know have been amazing
thing likes Elliot it's not as you like
you're doing your thing with the readers
its parts of those figure it out like it
seems like an editorial like you know
Wednesday to be I think the best way to
summarize all this information yeah
Prospero team I gave a talk there
earlier the summer and last summer and
one of the things that they're debating
right right now is kind of creating that
editorial hierarchy in the live thread
format so that you could have a couple
people who act as the editors as people
contribute to it so I guess like who
knows what they'll implement any changes
especially because like they have a
relatively small team compared to most
companies that have such popularity but
there are definitely some tweaks that
you could probably make to make it a bit
more efficient so it's just a matter of
if they have time do you think that's
likely to contribute to spread of
misinformation is it seems like it could
go that state operated very yeah yeah so
is there are some interesting case
studies the one that I mentioned earlier
with the Boston Marathon bombing what's
particularly interesting about that case
study though is there was a subreddit
that really screwed up by surfacing the
wrong information alongside that though
which wasn't highly covered in the press
were things more like the stuff I had
shown above which were like pretty well
documented updates about what was going
on kind of in this editorial comment
style format and so what happens it ends
up being kind of like on the part of the
editor or the common team to surface
Corrections and make it really clear
that like something has been changed or
something was wrong in the past and I
think we're that's very complicated is
like does the audience realize that it
was changed because it might not be
changed until the next day it might not
be changing to a cup
days later and that's kind of true of
any system right now that's working on
this problem it's how quickly can you
really surface visible signs of
something that's being corrected or
saying that something was wrong in time
for people to realize and really
internal I booth nefarious mob is going
into the community today because a lot
of community members feel like the mods
are already in the various enough and so
just like the deletions that happen it's
like mods are awful like get rid of the
hall and the mods mark we're just trying
to like get other news that's not just
all Paris or all whatever just happened
and so yes there have been instances
where a moderator either on purpose or
accidentally makes a bad decision that
significantly impairs the work that's
being done usually something gets
deleted and there have been cases where
even administrators have done some weird
stuff here and there so at the end of
the day it's that's not really like
regulations or or rules around this
stuff so people kind of got a deal i
guess but at the end of the day you
would hope that the community slowly
starts to build up these norms around
what's proper to do and just improve the
process overall
pork fingers in your arms great to have
you here
[Applause]